how's it going everybody it's Warren and
phase four is quickly approaching us the
full slate is expected to be revealed at
Disney's d23 event in August
Disney has stated that we will be
getting a look at the upcoming exciting
slate for Marvel Studios and with phase
4 arriving so quickly many people have
been asking the question how are the
next 10 years of the MCU going to be
better than the last 10 years of the MCU
especially with the build-up of the
Infinity stones and Thanos so the
question is what is Marvel going to do
to build up a villain and have him be
bigger and badder than Thanos well it
appears like we may have our answer
thanks to a leak online according to a
verified source the next chapter of the
MCU is going to have not one but two big
bad villains of the MCU I'll breakdown
these two villains in this video but
first a spoiler alert if you do not want
to know anything about the next phase
and future of the MCU this is your
opportunity to click away because again
this source has been verified to be
legitimate but of course with all leaks
take it with a grain of salt and if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe at the 450,000 subscriber mark
I will be picking three winners to
choose one item from a Marvel Legends
series collection all you have to do to
enter is be subscribed to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain so this leak comes
from reddit user the Marvel scoop master
and as I mentioned he was asked to
provide evidence or a source to verify
himself for this leak and he was in fact
verified and this leak says that we're
going to beginning to Thanos level big
bad villains one is going to be a ground
level threat and one is going to be a
cosmic threat this makes sense because
Marvel has been talking for a while now
saying that the future of the MCU is a
cosmic future having films like Captain
Marvel 2 taking place in space and of
course guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and
introducing new movies as well but at
the same time we're of course also going
to have heroes on earth so it would make
sense that we have two Big Bad villains
now Kevin Feige stated that nothing
about phase 4 is going to be revealed
until after spider-man far from home and
according to this leak the reason for
that is because we are going to get
introduced to Norman Osborn in
spider-man far from
and he of course will be the big bad
ground villain this leak says that it's
likely we'll see his goblin alter-ego
but it is important to note that we'll
be seeing Norman using political and
economical power to exude control over
people his art will pool heavily from
Dark Reign and potentially his run with
the Thunderbolts this makes sense
because the famous leaker Roger Waddell
has tweeted about a Thunderbolts trilogy
being planned and as far as the cosmic
threat goes according to this leak the
big bad cosmic villain is going to be
Michael Kovak this is a name that has
not been mentioned or expected at all as
a villain for phase 4 but according to
this leak he will tie in with a Captain
Marvel sequel and eventually become a
threat for the larger cosmic MCU korvac
becoming a main cosmic villain actually
ties into Marvel introducing the
multiverse in the comics Corvette comes
from a alternate universe earth six nine
one interestingly enough people thought
that we might see core vac and guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 because in the
comics korvac is transported throughout
time by the Grandmaster who we saw in
thor ragnarok he is used as a pawn by
the Grandmaster but eventually plans to
conquer the cosmos he leads a group of
aliens called the minions of Menace and
attempts to cause the Earth's Sun to go
Nova but he is defeated by the guardians
of the galaxy and Thor now we know
Avengers endgame set up Thor to be with
the guardians of the galaxy which is why
some people expected Corvette to be in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and he
very well could make some sort of an
appearance but according to this leak he
is going to be the next big bad cosmic
villain of the MCU so according to this
leak these are the two big bad villains
that are going to be coming to the MCU
Norman Osborn isn't much of a surprise
we've already heard leaks about this in
the past but korvac is certainly a very
interesting surprise but a very exciting
choice that offers a lot of possibility
for the future of the MCU so let me know
what you think about this leak and again
although it's verified please take it
with a grain of salt
but what do you think about Norman
Osborn being the ground villain and core
vac being the cosmic villain of the
future of the MCU do you think these two
villains can be built up like they built
up Thanos and the Infinity Gauntlet saga
let me know how you feel about this and
again a reminder
about my giveaway at the 450,000
subscriber mark I'll be picking three
winners and each gets to choose one item
from the Marvel Legends series
collection all you have to do to enter
for your chance to win is be subscribed
to my channel like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero or villain
and of course as always thank you all so
much for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you said it cost you everything while
crying like a baby